speaking of being right speaking of  attacks speaking of the libs desecrating  things speaking of tweets speaking of  guys who just constantly defend the  liberal status quo speaking of Democrats  harming children speaking of crooked  plans speaking of Democrats weird  obsession with our children speaking of  childish behavior speaking of  hyper capitalism speaking of less than  ideal Arrangements speaking of church  speaking of the Muslims speaking of  things you're not allowed to say  speaking of insanity in New York  speaking of sexual eccentricity speaking  of lives mattering speaking of sexual  confusion speaking of  undignified Behavior